fait une promesse et à 4-5 ans alors sur
ce plateau quoi vous êtes alors ah oui
une vraie promesse et on sait à quel
point vous vous ce vous savez bien sûr
tenir je suis pas bien parce que non
même pas être bien c'est quoi le bail
babau c'est quoi le bail regarder quels
animateurs
[Applaudissements]
je t'aime bien voir sur le plateau mais
je vais t'en passer comme chat mais toi
je t'explique que je vais cadeaux chez
mais je te kiffe mais de golf voile
alors et je suis avec toi je te kiffe
tu es ma vie et mon été ma passion voilà
je t'aime le même esprit que je vais
cadeaux chez les ch'tis
[Applaudissements]
dir
pourquoi on peut pas on est trop potes
on se connaît trop bien et je ne peux
pas galocher quelqu'un de ma famille a
entendu non mais c'est vrai c'est quoi
ta tête je suis prise en plus donc je
suis désolé avec tout le monde est pris
tout mais j'ai toujours avec moi une
doublure galoche
c'est vrai ouais tu là ne reçoit rien
c'est pas hervé ouais parce que tu n'as
tu as toujours une doublure galoche
ouais je la mène toujours avec moi en
cas de coups durs c'est pas mariés sevgi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
panique au petit boulot se dit
officiellement boulot
[Musique]
enthousiaste cadeaux
les rouleaux aller selon m
excuse moi je sais quoi dacquois ma paie
pas les choses alors c'est pour quand
même fait pas les choses à pousser les
cheveux lente émission s'est jamais su
alors cyril zimmermann à la merci de
rendre l'argent
[Applaudissements]
non je suis allée contraire c'est le
seul mec et céline bracq conclure une
non on est bête
je suis une battante au rythme attention
c'est le premier c'est moi qui donne la
note
[Musique]
non
je demande la chance parce que moi aussi
j'ai toujours une doublure galoche
humala
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais
allez 20 de ces camps
merci
antoine on peut l'applaudir
[Applaudissements]